Aubrey Plaza's career is on fire now,
but a medical setback nearly 20 years ago
threatened to end it before it ever began.
In 2004, while she was a 20 year old undergraduate
at New York University, Aubrey Plaza suffered
a stroke that left her temporarily
paralyzed, without the ability to speak.
In a 2016 interview with the Guardian, Plaza
shared that she'd suffered from aphasia,
a disorder which can severely impact one's
ability to communicate. She explained,
"I had expressive aphasia, where I
could understand what's happening,
but I couldn't talk or communicate.
Like, you could say something and I
would know what you meant but I couldn't
express it or even write it. [...] When
they gave me a piece of paper and a pen I
just kept writing lines instead of words."
"And every time they asked me how old I was,
I would go, 'Sixteen,' which was the only
number I could say. I don't know why."
Plaza added that immediately after
having the stroke — which happens
when either blood is prevented from
getting to the brain or a blood vessel
within the brain itself bursts —
she couldn't walk. She recalled,
"When it first happened to me I was paralyzed,
but I was so young that my brain healed itself
really fast. I was really lucky in that way."
Maybe the most frightening part of the entire
ordeal, as Plaza explained to Fresh Air in 2017,
is that, because she appeared okay when she got
to the emergency room, she wasn't examined right
away. However, when she was, her condition
was immediately apparent. As she remembered,
"A doctor finally examined me, and I
believe she asked me to put my right
hand on my left knee. And I couldn't
do it. I was confused about right and
left. And I think that's when everyone
realized, oh, like, she had a stroke."
Plaza has been remarkably
open about what happened,
which is helpful to other stroke victims who may
be reluctant to talk about their experience for
fear of being stigmatized. Strokes are, in fact,
distressingly common. As Plaza told Fresh Air,
she was visiting a friend at their apartment.
They were discussing a Hilary Duff concert
she'd attended with her sister, when she
blacked out mid-sentence. When she came to,
she couldn't speak. Though her friends
thought she was joking at first,
they eventually realized that it was serious
and called an ambulance. Plaza told Fresh Air,
"There was no recovery. I
mean when you have a stroke,
you have a stroke. There's nothing you can
do about it. Your brain has to heal itself."
Plaza added that she still has lingering
complications from the experience,
even after cognitive therapy and a
successful recovery. As she explained,
"But I still have [...] things
that only I would notice that
are kind of [...] left over from
that incident. And since then,
I've had some minor — they call them TIAs,
which are transient ischemic attacks,
that are tiny little strokes. So something's
up with my blood, but I don't know what it is."
Just a few years after her
devastating medical setback,
Plaza landed her career-defining role. In 2009,
she introduced the world to sullen intern April
Ludgate on the NBC sitcom Parks and Recreation.
"April Ludgate, professional drinker."
Despite a slow start, the show
hit its stride in Season 2,
and Plaza's hilariously deadpan
April was a huge part of its success.
Alongside an all-star cast that included Amy
Poehler, Chris Pratt, Aziz Ansari, Adam Scott, Rob
Lowe, Rashida Jones, Jim O'Heir, Retta, and Nick
Offerman, Plaza helped make Parks and Recreation
one of the most beloved shows of the 2010s.
And despite its consistently low ratings, the
show's following and the love it got from critics
helped it run for a solid seven seasons. Still,
the best was yet to come for Plaza, who didn't let
her medical situation keep her from her acting.
Plaza's career remained healthy after
Parks and Recreation. She appeared in
films like Mike and Dave Need Wedding Dates
and Ingrid Goes West as well as the small
screen series Legion. And in 2022, she
embarked on an entirely new creative
journey with Season 2 of Mike White's hit
anthology series The White Lotus. White
Lotus allowed the actor to flex her muscles
as a performer and ultimately got attention
from the Television Academy in the form of
a supporting actress Emmy nomination. And,
scary medical history or not, Plaza shows
no signs of slowing down anytime soon.